Uh, before
we get out for our For the Win,
uh, you guys... uh, you guys
at home have been tweeting
#MyLoveLifeIn5Words jokes
all night,
but I want the #Soulmates
over here a chance
to each throw in one
of their own, so ladies first.
-Emily.
-All right.
I'd have to say...
"Mmm, pull down my Spanx,
cowboy."
-All right, very good.
Points to you. -Oh! Very nice.
And now, uh...
Brian, you got to top that.
I... I might be able to. Um...
Emily, will you marry me?
(cheering, applause)
Holy (bleep)!
Yes! Yes!
Yes!
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
Hang on.
Yes!
-You good?
-Oh, my... Yes!
Wait, wait, wait, wait
wait, wait! Wait.
Oh, my God!
Everyone was screaming.
You said yes, right?
-Yes. -Okay, good, okay, good.
That would have been really...
-Yes!
-...really unfortunate.
He liked it!
-And he put a ring on it!
-How are you doing?
-Doing all right.
-Oh, my God. -Look at this!
-Did you have any idea
this was coming? -No! No!
Oh, my God.
Brian, you had to...
How are you feeling?
I'm feeling pretty good right
now. -You are feeling
-pretty good right now.
Yeah, yeah. -Yeah.
That would explain the... your
pants slowly filling with poop
for, like, the first half
of the show...
-Yeah, pretty much.
-...figuring out how to do this.
But, uh, what a great... So you
got-you got engaged on the show
that you guys
initially bonded over.
Now you're gonna go get married,
so we'll bring that back
-onto the show at some point.
-Oh, my God!
-(cheering, applause)
-Congratulations.
I want you to...
I want you to name
your first kids together
@midnight Hardwickton III.
-Think it's a great name
for a kid. -Of course.